our big traffic story is the complete  shutdown of Las Vegas Boulevard yeah the  strip is shut down between convention  center and Resorts World because of this  now this happened at 1 30 this morning  so more than four hours ago a fatal  crash right at the entrance to Resorts  World wanted to show you some video from  up above as well as down below the  stratcam capturing this scene shortly  after the crash occurred we also have  video from down on the ground meanwhile  back to the live camera the traffic  computer Metro Police still with the  yellow tape there's a convention center  and Elvis Presley is up there by the  fountain blue no word when it's going to  reopen so how do you get around well you  get over to Paradise via Spring Mountain  or Sahara